foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
saw this play before he even caught the
ball so it was just a matter of
delivering
[Applause]
oh and what a fancy pass a great finish
but the pass woo
[Music]
here's LeBron all once again
[Applause]
a little bounce and the hit comes right
back down between the legs with the
bounce on techio nuggets him away they
got a long pass to jokic behind the back
to Porter nicely done to execute almost
all there by Hayes real good in terms of
goodness
that is a pass of the Year candidate
right
wood with the pass Luca able to chase it
down they got it trapped on the sideline
they fouled in a situation like that
before
uh you're not going to win it he'll find
you yeah he just looked up and realized
we're the only place he could put that
ball Jaden Hardy as possible
[Applause]
Caesar
Dylan Brooks
thank you OKC into the lane
Showtime
Giannis touches the paint sprays it out
Allen got it 40 after three wall behind
the back the dish to Brown the flush
with two and the Clippers leakage trim
the lead to six but Moses Brown stealing
the show here in the second half
[Applause]
11 points four assists three rebounds
for Butler much more aggressive
then in game one you can touch past the
garden
Curry now with the shooter on his back
oh what a pass what a finish look at
this pass up in the air oh man and then
finds Steven shenza right now man drives
[Applause]
the same the three-pointer is gone
oh wow again it's preseason Sarah it's
preseason
yeah Irving the steal Scoops it up ahead
streaky to the rim O'Neill
[Applause]
I think that's exactly what he wanted to
do the 8-90 to four Court
against out third to the corner on him
behind the back no looker inside tomadu
55-39
[Applause]
baby
taken by Halliburton yeah when a guy
picking Buddy Hill was back there with
them heart and they were able to get it
and no look gives it to me
turns on Reed
oh behind the back pass to Christopher
[Applause]
the cows have had their shares of
streaks as well this season as Mitchell
Oklahoma
by Donovan Mitchell to set up the Mobley
done I'm Gonna Save him for a little bit
[Applause]
oh it's two Sixers hit the deck they
couldn't stop John he's limping a bit 22
games now where he's been in double
figures a good player
jokic coming in over the shoulder to
Gordon what a beauty
[Music]
Diallo takes it to the right bangs
inside misses the shot Zoo has it with
two minutes to play in the third
punches a little in the right hand
o'donovich Rodney pocket pass it to uh
Durham turns it over Trey
[Applause]
McDermott having problems Reed's got a
hand on a three on one Russ LeBron runs
to LeBron throw that baby down it is the
most in the NBA since Washington had 96
in 2021 bones
[Applause]
in the first half until then huh look at
a nice move through traffic what a pass
and the three is made by Timothy Duane
Hardaway
Gulliver's Travels to land in the little
futures
what
Blazers it in the Christian Wood on
football going on it looks like the
interception from a DV
D cool driving oh no looks at command
Showtime yeah it's amazing how Doc is
finding his lineup is
fade inside I'm a nola from Darius
Garland be short rebound Moran
ahead
yeah exactly what you're thinking
all right
and a good play by Jeff Green to cut off
the Baseline there goes bones High
stepping oh
a put away not just a long-range shooter
lavello creatively to McDaniels
there's a nice driving dish by car oh
what a pass Wiggins for three
can you get an easy transition basket
right now
oh great pass
o
in the game doncic oh bounce pass from a
sitting position and it was an absolute
dime for a jam
just an all-around struggle again for
the Lakers and I I hate to keep harping
on it but I'm gonna harp this team
cheats left front Reeves Corner that
comes up way short Austin though Gabriel
[Applause]
gotta get Yorkies going but they're
doubling him every time
Cross Court sling and kcp is going to be
a four-point opportunity
lamelo hadn't done anything in a while
[Applause]
[Music]
behind me that how about that
this just a third game back after their
annual nine-game road trip over the
shoulder like for green two Shin goon
back out there
missed the shot pass that's amazing
stuff by Alfredo
[Applause]
save the defense the shot no good now
Portland has the numbers stolen by folks
again dunked in by Bandero that's great
that's that time off a rebound on a very
difficult shot
oh one Late Three he would have went for
it
okay yep yep
[Applause]
going along
he does Murray shot good if it goes
missed it rebounded by bull
a long pass perfectly thrown and frogs
Bodner
taking nearly about 48 games
touchdown came into Bobby Portis inside
Tatum beautiful pass to Brogden boy two
highlight plays from the Bostons
cool the ball handling skills
[Applause]
what a look cool to die Vincenzo the
perfect amount of spin on the bounces
never thought that his athleticism was
off the charge like this
what a pass Chris Paul Fine large with
defensive effort it's been pretty decent
back pass
it to see Orlando on Saturday coming off
the win over AKC
what a disc to Looney you make him go
back right I don't think it says he's a
nice play there
[Applause]
for three
[Music]